Hi.
My name is Roman Nurik from the
Android team at Google.
And in today's design, I'd like
to talk to you about how
screen pixel density affects
your workflow as an Android
App Designer.
Let's take a look.
So the first thing to understand
is that Android
devices come in all
shapes and sizes.
And the screens on these
devices have
different pixel densities.
And this number is measured
in dots per inch, or DPI.
And these pixel densities simply
say in a given square,
say, inch of space on
the screen, how many
pixels will fit in?
And this determines very much
the level of crispness that
you're going to see graphics and
text and things like that
on that screen.
So in this example, here a
couple of different DPI
values, possible DPI values and
how text, in this case,
the letter a, would be rendered
on those screens.
You'll notice that on the higher
density screens, the
letter A is rendered in a much
more crisp, a much more almost
correct representation of the
letter A than on the medium
density screens on the left.
Now as a designer, these pixel
densities like 165, 234 and so
on, could be very cumbersome
to work with.
So fortunately, Android has
created something called
logical pixel densities, or
buckets of densities that the
real densities would fall into,
to simplify things.
So here on screen, you see a
couple of the key, the most
important logical densities that
you as a designer would
have to work with.
So something like, if a real
device had 165 DPI screen,
that would be mapped
down to 160 DPI.
And then everything that you
would do from that point on,
you wouldn't have to worry
about the 165 number.
You simply think about, oh this
screen I will treat as a
160 DPI screen.
And 160 DPI is a
special value.
It's something called the
baseline density in Android,
where everything, and
specifically the density
independent pixel units we'll
talk about in a second, where
everything is based on this
baseline density.
So that's 160 DPI.
At the other far end of the
spectrum currently, the
highest number, the highest
logical density is extra extra
high DPI, or XXHDPI, which
is 480 dots per inch.
And so there are four specific
densities between 160 and 480
that you should really
be aware of.
That's 160, 240, 320, and 480.
And there are a couple that
are not listed here.
There's LDPI at 120 and TVDPI
at 213, but those are less
common, and you generally
don't need
to worry about those.
So now that we understand
density, let's now talk about
something that's critical to
designing for Android, and
that's the density-independent
pixel unit.
Now, density-independent pixel
units, which are sometimes
abbreviated as DP, or DIP,
sometimes referred to as DIPs
in conversation.
They are a virtual pixel unit,
and they're equivalent to one
physical pixel--
that's one physical pixel on the
screen on a MDPI, or 160
DPI screen.
And now if you have a single
density independent pixel on a
MDPI screen, that's one
physical pixel.
But if you're on a larger
screen, let's say an XHDPI
screen, it's actually
four pixels, two
across and two down.
So why do we use density
independent pixels?
Well, the reason for that is
that we want to make sure that
when we create layouts, and
overall kind of define the
user interface for our
application, we want to make
sure that UI elements remain
the same physical size,
approximately, across devices
with different densities.
We don't want to have to specify
for each individual
density what the sizes of our
UI elements should be.
So let's look at an example.
So here we have 200 dips, and
again, dip units or DP units
keep things roughly the same
physical size across devices.
So we have 200 DP units and we
have, let's say, this wide
purple rectangle
that's spanning
across a couple devices.
Now on an MDPI device, like the
tablet you see here, 200
DPs will actually result
in something that
is 200 pixels tall.
So again, one DP is
one pixel at MDPI.
Now on an XHDPI device like this
Nexus 4 here, the 200 DPs
will actually become
400 pixels tall.
And this is actually
built-in behavior.
If you specify that something
should be 200 DP, it'll be the
same physical size on
different devices.
Now one interesting thing about
DP units is that since
they're the same physical size
across devices, we can start
representing physical objects
in terms of DPs.
So for example, the fingertip,
the human fingertip is about
50 DPs wide.
Now what that means is that
when you are sizing your
buttons and other UI elements,
you want to make sure that
things don't get too small,
small enough to touch.
You want to make sure they're
about the size of a human
fingertip so that a regular
person could comfortably press
that button without making
too many mistakes.
So let's look at some math
that will help us get
comfortable with converting
between pixels and DP units.
Now here's the only real
formula you need.
To solve for one of the
variables, you simply plug in
the other two.
So let's look at
some examples.
So here's the definition
of DPs.
One pixel is one dip or one dip
is one pixel at 160 DPI.
Easy enough.
Now on a 320 DPI screen, one dip
is actually two pixels--
two pixels across and
two pixels down.
So let's actually put this
equation in practice, and look
at a quick exercise.
So how big is the 2013
Nexus 7 screen in
density-independent pixels?
Now the information we have is
that we know that the screen
is seven inches across
diagonally.
We know that it's an XHDPI
screen, meaning
it's a 320 DPI screen.
And we also know that the screen
resolution is 1920 by
1200 pixels.
And so the first thing you may
want to ask yourself is, what
information here is necessary?
Now the fact that it's a seven
inch screen here is not
actually necessary.
To calculate the number of
density-independent pixels, we
don't actually need the diagonal
screen size if we
have the number of pixels
and the density.
So if you look at the formula
from before, you'll notice
that the ratio between XHDPI
and MDPI is two to one.
So to convert from pixels to DP
units on an XHDPI device,
you simply divide by two.
So the answer here is 1920
divided by 2 by 1200 divided
by 2, or simply 960 by 600
density-independent pixels.
So you may be asking, what's the
point of this calculation?
Well, the reason is that
density-independent pixels
better capture device physical
screen size.
Pixels could be the same across
devices of different
screen sizes.
For example, you can have a
medium-density tablet at 1280
by 800 pixels, and an extra
high-density phone at 1280 by
720 pixels.
And their screen resolutions in
pixels are almost the same.
But that same phone will
actually have a much smaller
screen resolution when
looked at in terms of
density-independent pixels.
And so density-independent
pixels better capture that.
So with that, let's move
on to some quick tips
before we sign off.
So first, remember to design and
spec all of your layout in
terms of arrangement of UI
elements, the sizes of
elements, the positions
of elements.
Make sure to spec that
all out in DP units.
It's going to make it a lot
easier for your developers to
implement things correctly.
Second, remember that because
there are a number of
different densities, for optimal
crispness of assets
you want to make sure that you
provide those graphic assets,
those PNG files in all the
different densities.
So here's an example
of a share icon.
You want to make sure that
you're providing it in four
different densities, if
possible, in XHDPI all the way
down to MDPI.
And to do again the calculation
for the sizes of
these things, you simply use
the formula we used before.
So if we know that we want to
have a 32 DP square icon,
we'll know that on an XXHDPI
device, the asset you need for
that should be 96
by 96 pixels.
So that's it on today's design
byte on how screen density,
and specifically,
density-independent pixels
should affect your workflow
as a designer.
Stay tuned for more design bytes
on how to put this into
practice in tools like
Photoshop and
Illustrator and so on.
Thanks.